>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> John Cole: Well,
good evening, everyone.
Welcome to The Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the Director of The
Library's Center for the Book,
which means I have the lucky job of
promoting books, reading, literacy
and libraries on behalf of
The Library of Congress.
And tonight we have a special
treat, not only a special speaker,
Lisa Scottoline, but also
a number of guests who are
with us from other countries.
They're visiting today and part of a
program at The Library of Congress.
Today we've announced our
new 2015 Literacy Awards,
which means the Library is honoring
organizations from around the world
that have made achievements
towards erasing illiteracy.
It's an important five-year
program funded by David Rubenstein,
one of the Library's benefactors,
and it really recognizes
not only three major groups
that get cash prizes for
the work they've done,
but also best practices.
These are the people who are
with us today are the honorees
and there were 14 organizations
honored by The Library
of Congress Literacy
Awards this year and 12
of them are represented today at
the Library, several from overseas,
to talk about their
best practices projects.
And this is a booklet which covers
and tells you the whole story
and I hope you'll take one
with you when you leave.
It talks about the awards,
it talks about the winners,
and each of our best
practice winners
who is here tonight knows very
well from this afternoon's program,
where they all presented
information about their projects,
that they each have a page and
which describes their project,
and we encourage them to use that
page and to use the recognition
by The Library of Congress
to help further literacy,
their literacy efforts in their
countries, but also to be part
of this larger effort
to eradicate illiteracy
by re-stimulating interest
in literacy
and literacy promotion
throughout our society.
Now a number of these people, Lisa,
I'm sorry to say may not know your
books, but we also have friends
and fans of Lisa's who have come
to hear her introduce her new book
and we have managed to
combine these two efforts
because of Lisa's own support of The
Library of Congress and her interest
in our activities and in
particular something I'm grateful
for is her support for the Center
for the Book and its activities.
The Center was created in
1977 by Daniel Boorstin
when he was Librarian of
Congress and he wanted The Library
of Congress to reach out to society
to promote books and reading.
This was before literacy was really
even a hot word and we, of course,
became the natural place in the
Library for the Literacy Awards,
just as we were the focal point
for the National Book Festival
when it was created in 2001
by First Lady Laura Busch,
who when her husband was elected
President of the United States,
she was the First Lady of Texas and
had created the Texas Book Festival.
And she quickly said that it was her
goal when she came to Washington was
to create a National Book
Festival and that, by golly,
she was going to invite The Library
of Congress to be the partner.
And she said that immediately
and I'm so grateful she said it
because eventually, of
course, not eventually,
the following spring we had the
first National Book Festival.
And her staff combined with Dr.
Boorstin's staff, including the kind
of headed by me at the
time with the assignment
of getting the National
Book Festival started.
We did not have our first planning
meeting until April in 2001
and the first Book Festival
was held in The Library
of Congress buildings, plus
on the East Capitol grounds,
on September the 8th.
So we had about three months to plan
and we ended up, to our amazement
and delight, having 30,000 people
who flooded the Jefferson building
and this building and we knew there
never again should be one inside.
But this was accentuated
three days later with 9-11
and I thought there would never
be another National Book Festival.
But Mrs. Bush insisted and
by then it was Dr. Billington
who was Librarian of Congress
immediately got in touch
and it turned out that
Mrs. Bush said, yes,
of all things it's
even more important
to have a National Book
Festival in a time like this.
And it really is through
the National Book Festival
and the activities of the Center for
the Book actually that I met Lisa.
She probably won't remember
when I think we first met,
which was in Florida when you were
doing a talk for the Florida Center
for the Book for Jean
Trevy [Assumed Spelling].
You do remember?
And I was visiting with my
wife and we were, of course,
as the honcho of the huge Center
for the Book back in Washington,
with Florida being our first
Center, it was important that I go
to some events, especially
since it was in Ft.
Lauderdale.
And we met Lisa and had dinner with
her and went to her presentation
and just about that time the
National Book Festival was getting
started and Lisa became really -
we invited her to the Book Festival
and she first came, and I actually
looked this up as a Librarian,
2007 was your first
National Book Festival.
But the thing about Lisa that I
recall always was, first of all,
she's a lawyer and she
chose to write mysteries.
My wife Nancy was a mystery,
still is a mystery buff,
and so a lot of these worlds came
together for me and, of course,
I pretended like I knew
lots of mystery writers.
Well, I did know one for sure
and she became a mystery writer
with her writing career
beginning with her first novel,
Everywhere Mary Went,
which was published
in 1994 before we had
a Book Festival.
It became a bestseller and was
nominated for the Edgar Award,
which is the most prestigious
award given in crime fiction.
Her second novel, Final Appeal,
received the 1995 Edgar Award.
Today she has written
more than 25 books,
many of which have appeared
on bestseller lists.
And just to take the last bit of
the blurb, which is important,
today more than 30 million
copies of her books are in print
and are published in more than
35 countries in 25 languages.
Today, Lisa, we had a
real international meeting
as you can imagine with reports
from these various countries
about literacy and reading in their
countries and your books are in many
of their countries, probably
all of their countries.
But she is a special friend of
the Library and our Book Festival.
As I said, her first appearance was
2007 and for one of her mysteries.
You were also at the 2009, but what
I really remember was the first time
you came with your daughter.
And so this was a new pattern that
emerged with the 2012 Book Festival
when she, when Lisa
came and spoke twice
and this was a first
for the Book Festival.
Once as a mystery writer, in those
days we called it the Fiction
and Mystery Pavilion, and
the book was Come Home.
A second time in that same Festival
2012 with Francesca, her daughter,
in our newly created
Contemporary Life,
which was a wonderful Pavilion, for
their joint book of funny stories
and true confessions, which
was titled Best Friends,
Occasional Enemies, The Lighter Side
of Life as a Mother and Daughter.
Well, mother and daughter made
another joint appearance this year
at the National Book Festival.
Lisa going it alone in mysteries,
thrillers and science fiction.
We keep changing the Pavilions
because our Book Festival keeps
expanding and we're trying
to get more genres, but there's
always, whatever Pavilion Lisa is
in always has the word
mystery in it.
And that book was Every Fifteen
Minutes and, again, with Francesca
in contemporary life, and this
time was for their latest together,
which was titled Does This
Beach Make Me Look Fat?
So you can see you have a skilled
writer, a diverse writer in front
of you, and tonight she
will be signing copies
of her brand-new book, which
was just published today,
and it is called?
>> Lisa Scottoline: Corrupted.
>> John Cole: All right.
So we're lucky Lisa is with us,
we're lucky to have our Best
Practices winners with us.
We've had a wonderful afternoon,
an inspiring afternoon
I think for many of us.
And we know that Lisa will give
us another form of inspiration,
and may I introduce Lisa Scottoline.
[ Applause ]
>> Lisa Scottoline: John, John -
how much do we love John
Cole, then we love John Cole?
My God, let's hear it?
[applause] This man is amazing.
And Robert Newlyn [Assumed Spelling]
and everybody who worked so hard.
I am so honored to be here.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations to
all of the winners
and to all the Best
Practices finalists.
I am in awe.
I am distinctly unworthy.
I am your comic relief tonight.
I can tell you I feel as if, though,
maybe I have something to offer you
because I think I always begin
because you are all doing stuff
that is so important and so in
my mind macro really that I want
to take you to the
micro a little bit.
Because I think if I get this
speech right I should be able to end
up in a place where you understand
at a very granular level,
as everybody says these days,
how very important you are.
And I think an author might
be the person to tech you that
or just remind you of that.
because I come to you not only as
an author, but more importantly
as a person who loves books and
grew up in a house with none, none.
We had lots of hugs
in South Philadelphia,
lots of meatballs, but one book.
What do you think that book was?
>> Bible.
>> Lisa Scottoline: The
Bible, aren't you sweet.
No, no, I said its South
Philly where we keep it real,
and the book was TV Guide.
Nobody read in my house,
nobody read.
So when I started reading my
mother said, please stop reading,
you'll ruin your eyes,
what are you doing?
It was that kind of a vibe.
They loved me a lot, but it was a
school librarian who took me aside
and said, go tell your father
to take you to a library.
And then he took me to the library
where he sat in the car like a dog
because there was no
TV in the library then.
Now there's TV in the library maybe
this Scottoline had a fighting
chance, but then he was there.
And so I was in the library
and I was that kid wandering
in the library, probably not unlike
a lot of the kids you're helping,
though the setting is different.
I'm talking about Winfield,
Pennsylvania,
somewhere outside of Philadelphia.
To me, the setting
matters not at all.
Because somewhere there's a kid
wandering in some library going, a,
I'm intimidated but, b,
I'm also a little in love.
It's kind of like Bradley Cooper
now that I just thought of it,
intimidated and also in love.
How to reconcile?
We don't know.
But here I was in the library going,
how do I pick a book, I
don't know what to do?
And in those days, you know,
the cards went with the books.
People wrote with something
called a pencil, you may remember.
Do you own one?
No. But I remember look at that
nice handwriting, she looks nice,
maybe I'll get this book.
But what really helped me
choose books was on the spine,
a lot of the books,
they had a person
in profile with a really big nose.
The Scottolines have
really big noses.
My mother says we get more
oxygen than anyone in the room.
And she's right, like if I
breathe in you could die,
like it could be it
was nice knowing you.
But here I was and I'm looking
at that guy with that nose
and I'm going, you know, I'm feeling
him, like he's a little Uncle Rocky.
So I read all those books and then
at some point I find out that he's -
his name is Sherlock Holmes,
and that's why I'm a
mystery writer today.
It was very glamorous.
I really wanted to class
it up for you guys,
but obviously I had
to tell the truth.
But the important point
about that, though,
is that is where I found somebody
that actually led me on a path
that would take me here, amazingly
enough, which was Nancy Drew.
Can we talk about the
girl detective?
Because we need to talk
about the girl detective.
And I will tell you as an author
that anybody who is worth your time,
writing anything, is going to try
to choose telling details, right?
Now if you think about what Nancy
Drew had, she had a best girlfriend
because we all have
girlfriends, yay.
She had a boyfriend because
she's not a middle-aged woman,
just saying.
Real, let's be real.
Is my bitterness showing?
Good, fine, excellent.
She had a father, kind
of benign presence.
I think of him like Jimmy Stewart.
Does anyone know who that is?
Good, then we can keep
talking, excellent.
And she lacked a mother.
Remarkable, please note
To Kill a Mockingbird.
There's a reason this happens, when
there's not a mother in the picture,
like my mother would
have her in a convent.
But the child can go
on adventures and be
on her own when there's no mother.
Nancy Drew, the telling detail on
Nancy Drew if I may suggest to you
if you think about what you
remember about Nancy Drew,
isn't it the blue roadster,
remember the car?
There's a reason for that.
Go back in American
history to the 1950s,
see the USA in your Chevrolet.
Go back to Bruce Springsteen,
even that is a dated
reference, which is horrifying.
Like what?
But think of Thunder Road, right?
These four wheels will
take you anywhere.
There's something about
a car that we think
of as quintessentially American,
and Nancy Drew within a car.
And the most important
thing about Nancy Drew
in that very telling detail
of a roadster is what?
She's in the driver's seat.
She is nobody's passenger.
She is an American girl
having adventures on her own.
What's she doing?
Frankly, I'm just here to
tell you it doesn't matter
because all the plots
are - well, she's - well,
I'll tell you what the plot
is, she's missing something
and she has to find it, okay?
Everything is missing in
the town in which she lives.
The clocks are missing.
The pencils are missing.
There's a missing staircase,
which I think is remarkable
because I might misplace my phone
but I know where my staircases are,
like I'm all over the staircases.
But none of that matters,
I can tell you
as a writer that's just
the top line of the plot.
You won't remember
a Nancy Drew plot,
what you remember is the
girl and the roadster.
And so here I am falling in love in
the library, going I want to be her,
I want to drive like her.
And then I grow up and I have a
lifelong love of reading thanks
to librarians because though
I was so deeply loved at home,
I can't say that I was
honestly understood.
The place where they
understood me was
where the books were,
with the librarians.
And they gave me something
called the library card
in a time when I wanted mail.
I wanted a wallet filled
with identification.
I had nothing, but I
had a library card.
It was orange and stiff and it
had a little metal plate, right?
My card number was 3839.
Why do I remember that and I don't
remember where my cell phone is?
I would go home and ink it, this
is how geeky I was, I would ink it
like this and like put it on things.
Why? Why, because I
was pathetic, that too,
but because there's an emotional
- the librarians the library made
for me an emotional
connection with the book,
that you remember what you
are emotionally connected.
That's why I remember
the things in my life
that really matter and so do you.
Because that library card
was more than a library card,
it was a passport,
it's a you belong.
Here's a club and we love you.
We don't think it's crazy
you want to read your eyes
out of your head, we
think it's cool.
And that's what libraries do for
everybody and that's why I get
to sort of stand before you today.
Not only did they give me a
lifetime, lifetime love of reading
and a career besides, but
I feel like the best part
of my career is sort
of my secret message.
Now I don't say this often,
but you brought it out in me
so it's all your fault,
but when I started
to become a writer I thought what
can I contribute, what can I do?
And I had been a lawyer,
I loved being a lawyer.
I only became a writer
after my first divorce.
Are you impressed yet?
You really should have had like Amy
Tan [Assumed Spelling] or somebody
who can stay married, but me?
I was like, ah, what am I
going to do now, you know?
I'm a lawyer, I'm getting divorced,
like my child is very young.
Like I hesitate to say this,
but I'm going to say this,
my child was basically crowning
at the time the divorce
was coming through.
I have to - it's such a good
verb, you can't really -
come on, it's a great verb.
That's where we were.
So I was like, oh, my God,
what am I going to do next?
Well, you loved me in Teacher and,
by the way, you're still reading
and all the stuff you read and not
only in mystery, but I must say
in crime fiction generally and in
popular fiction generally you had
to look very, very
hard for the heroines.
There were very few women
main characters and especially
in crime fiction because that's
all about the testosterone
and weapons offenses, you
know, and there's alcohol
and there's all this stuff.
And none of this stuff
I really related
to because I still
missed Nancy Drew.
And I said where is that plucky
American girl who is going
to find the missing whatever?
I said I guess you've
got to write that.
And part of me thought, you know,
look, I was a female lawyer.
Like, wow, you have a law degree and
ovaries, think of it, it happens.
So you had heard a lot about
Perry Mason, where's Della Street?
We were still pouring coffee
and so I said this must change.
And there I embarked upon my
main goal, which was to stay home
with my daughter, I must tell you.
And said what I can
contribute maybe is something
about women main characters
who may start out as lawyers,
but the cool thing about
it especially at that time
in the 1990s was that women -
part of what is amazingly charming
about us is that we don't
necessarily define ourselves
by our job.
If you think for a
moment about Perry Mason,
he's a guy in a courtroom,
he's a lawyer.
If you watched Perry Mason
or read Perry Mason you never
saw him outside of the courtroom.
You don't even know if he had
- well, he had a girlfriend
because he kind of had
Della Street whom he led
on unconscionably,
but he had no life.
He wasn't - there was a
cardboard characterization there
that women don't have
and didn't think of.
Because when I started writing I
was like, well, I'm a single mother.
I'm kind of like I was a
lawyer, but now I'm this.
What am I, what am I, what?
And that leads you to the
question of you're going write
about what is a woman and
you're going to tell it true.
Because as I always, my
touchstone is always a great quote
by Francis Ford Coppola,
the Director -
he said nothing my movies every
happened, but all of it is true.
Everything you write has to be
emotionally true or literally true
for it to connect, which
I'll come back to later.
In any event, I start writing,
writing, writing, writing.
I don't want you to think this is a
great fairytale because I was broke,
broke, broke, broke and
I got rejection letters
from a New York agent that said
things like we don't have time
to take any more clients and
if we did we wouldn't take you.
I see that guy every year at Book
Expo, where I was the keynote.
[applause] I know, revenge is sweet.
And I still see him, he's
calling me, he says, Lisa.
I don't hear you, I
don't, I don't hear you.
Yes, because my mother taught
me to keep hate alive and I do,
so I'm that petty really.
And so basically I embark upon this
writing life, which is wonderful
and hard to get into publication.
I'm living on credit cards, to
fast-forward through the story.
My daughter doesn't know that
we're broke, but we can do -
because we live on credit cards
and we pay like $10 a month,
they increase your
credit limit every time,
like they think you're a crack
addict and they're fine with that.
At 21%, exactly, right,
21% you could get money
from the mob cheaper, and
don't ask me how I know that.
so here I am, writing by day,
getting rejected by night,
nursing a child, happy as a clam
because I think I'm doing
something really important
which is raising this amazing
daughter and also trying
to tell stories about women
because I wanted to see us in print.
Fast-forward to when it finally gets
published, not for a living wage.
My daughter who had lived on credit
cards all her first six years had
to actually start to live
within her means, which sucked.
That's a literary term,
if you're not familiar.
Try to keep up with this, okay?
Permit me one cute kid
story, because we lived
on credit cards we would
go once a month to Chili's,
you know what Chili's is, right?
So she knew Chili's, like we would
go in Chili's and here's the menu
and eat this and she liked the
brownie sundae, it was a thing.
Well, she had never
been in a McDonald's
because it was the Dark Ages and
McDonald's did not take credit.
Can you imagine how
horrifying that would be?
Okay, so that meant she was not
going there because I did not have,
as we say in South Philly, scratch.
So we're driving, she would
want to go to McDonald's.
No, we can't.
Fast-forward to when
I finally sell a book
and we're going to McDonald's.
She is delighted, her eyes - she's
never seen a place like this,
it's like a child from
the Ukraine has been taken
and glistening surfaces,
it's remarkable.
And I say to her, but it's
not exactly like Chili's,
it's a little different,
you have to stand in a line.
At this point she's seven,
that's how long it took
me to get published.
And she looks up at the menu.
I said the menu is up there.
And she looks at it and she says,
but where are the appetizers?
Every head turns, this little
brat - I go she's broke,
she just doesn't know it.
And that's sort of the
stuff of it, you know?
It's you can't - it's
not a sob story.
To me, I want to be the person
who is Exhibit A and says to you
and this is the kind of stuff I
say at the National Book Festival
because I want not only
the kids, but the adults
to hear how a book gets made and
where it happens and why it matters.
And so I am lucky enough now
to write three books a year.
I write the Rosato Series, which
stars an all-woman law firm.
I still get the question,
is there such a thing
as an all-woman law firm?
Well, yes, there is because
I will answer that question
and I'll never - I might think
things, but I'll never say it
because part of what
I'm doing, you know,
no one wants to read a textbook
and no one wants to read a lecture.
My job is to entertain them
and have it dawn on them slowly
that these women are in control,
they're driving the roadster,
they're nobody's passengers.
And, by the way, the world didn't
end, it kind of worked out nice,
and the curtains are a
hell of a lot better.
I mean that's probably
sexist, but my point is this -
not to get ahead - Rosato
is about those women.
It's a series and it's about women
over time, and since I've been
at this so incredibly long I
am actually examining power
relationships and personal
relationships between women
over time and I'm talking
in real time,
like 20 years I've been
writing about these women.
So you're going to try to understand
how is the world different
when women run it?
Because that's what
happens in those books.
There are so many that I've
written a whole series of them,
and then there was a little
more insecure partner.
Let's think, she has fake blonde
hair and she's about five-two,
she's Italian-American, she
grew up in South Philly.
Oh, wait, it's supposed
to be fiction.
That would be Mary DiNunzio, who
is sort of like my alter ego.
And she was the insecure one
who actually became a partner,
so I had to reboot the series
as Rosato and DiNunzio.
I started it at Accused.
The next one last year was Betrayed.
This one is Corrupted.
You see the pattern
because you're smart people.
ABC, because Sue Grafton
is done with the alphabet
and there is no copyright
on that, and ain't it great?
In April I wrote books
which we call standalones,
they tend to examine
what is a mother?
This is all the secret
stuff I'm doing, right?
This is the stuff that matters,
not the stuff like this.
So here's, for example,
a quick story.
A lot of the books are
about what is motherhood,
how is step-motherhood
different because I've been that?
How is an adopted mother different?
Here's the story about that
and here's where it came from.
I was picking up my daughter who
grew up, actually stopped nursing
which was the beginning
of the end in my opinion,
but in any event goes
to college in Boston.
I have to pick her up.
Have you picked your
kid up at school?
Like you have to get all their
stuff in the car and take it home.
And I'm still single
so it's me and her,
like our Thanksgiving
is two people, whatever.
And we get all the stuff in the car.
She's got shoes, books,
DVDs, she's got earrings.
The parents of sons, they
have like baseball caps
and a basketball, but
I have everything.
I've packed the car.
On top of the car a mattress, a box
spring, a red rug which she insists
on keeping from her
dorm room, $37 rug.
I said let's toss it.
She's like, no, I really
want to keep it.
I deny her nothing.
We strap this thing with
a bungee cord, right?
It's a nightmare.
We drive home from
Boston to Philadelphia.
In Connecticut the worst
rainstorm ever in the history
of rainstorms happened,
and the red rug -
those of you who do laundry will
know exactly what happens next -
because the red rug, I'm
driving the blood mobile.
I had a white car and red
is leeching all over my car,
it looks like Stephen King.
I don't know what color plasma
is, but I'm pretty sure it was
in my windshield like a thin
red-yellow gruel, kind of revolting.
People on I-95 are
pointing and laughing,
who are these completely
crazy broads, honestly?
And we're laughing.
And at that moment I think to
myself this is so wonderful
because we basically were
laughing the next three states.
And I go I'm not going to have
this very much, many more years,
because she's growing up
and she's going to graduate.
And, you know, there's a joke that
says that what is the difference
between an Italian
mother and a Rottweiler,
and they say eventually
the Rottweiler lets go.
I don't think it's about Italianess,
I think it's about all good moms
and it's about all good dads.
You can't let them go.
And we got all - we had
this great talk in the car
and I remember picking her up.
You've had probably good talks
with your kids in the car, right?
There's something about
the car, right?
It's a little therapy on wheels
where they can't get out.
Like I always say it's
like wonderful,
and she always says it's a cage
match, so there's a difference.
In any event, I get home and
I had this moment where all
of my emotions well up, which is
a lot of emotion as you can see.
And I think to myself I'm
going to have to let her go
and this is going to be hard.
And then the next thought I had
was you're supposed to be a lawyer,
Scottoline, you framed
the question wrong.
She is not yours to let go,
you don't own her, poof,
your analysis is all wrong.
And as soon as I thought about
that I felt better in my heart,
I felt lighter, I was
like I can do this now
because I'm not letting her go.
And I said that's a novel,
that novel was Look Again.
That's what really
happened in Look Again,
that's the emotional
truth of Look Again.
But the top line plot, the
stupid missing staircase,
I shouldn't say stupid about my own
books, but you're working with me -
the top line plot is a woman.
Oh, let me get this
straight, it doesn't matter.
Fake blonde from the
Pennsylvania suburbs.
I'm the only person
I ever write about.
We understand that now.
She comes home one day and she gets
a card in the mail from missing
and abducted children, and she
looks at the picture in the middle.
It looks exactly like her
three-year-old son who was adopted.
Because in doing my research I
learn that it's practically true
in every jurisdiction in this
country that you can put up a baby
for adoption without producing
evidence or proof that it is yours.
You can't get out of Nordstrom's
writing a check unless you show them
your mortgage papers, but
you can say this is my baby
and they're fine with that.
So you know what's going to happen
on the first page of Look Again
because readers are smart,
and they say, well, listen,
this woman is going to
learn right then or suspect
that there's something wrong with
her adoption, unbenounced to her.
And she's going to start to think
to herself if I do the research
to find the truth I
may lose my child,
but if I keep this
secret I keep my child.
The question in Look Again is
who owns the child and it came
from the emotional truth
of the crappy $37 red rug.
Now what is all this?
And we write the humorous
ones in the summer,
which are about literal
truths and, frankly,
they're about the literal
truths of a woman's life.
So I write in all things as
a representative of capacity.
I got the idea for writing those
because I loved Erma Bombeck.
And I thought where is Erma Bombeck?
Where are the women's
voices that are listened to,
that are about just domestic issues?
Why just, why just, why
do we give that second,
why is that such short shrift?
And it was bothering me, but
I didn't think I could try
to write those things because I felt
like I had a kind of a funny family.
Like I said, like we're like
there's no husband, it's me
and a daughter, it's kind of weird.
And so I felt distinctly
inept, unworthy.
This is my favorite
emotion generally, insecure.
So I'm at a library
fundraiser at Laguna Niguel.
Laguna Niguel is a very
fancy place in California,
and I sort of said something
like I'm divorced twice,
which is not something I used to
lead with, now I'm a little older,
everything loosens up as you
hit 60 or whatever, we all live.
I'm in Laguna Niguel, I hear people
going, oh, I'm divorced four times.
No, I'm divorced five times.
Like I need to move
to Laguna Niguel.
But what was interesting is I heard
these women start talking instantly
about what?
Dogs, their dogs.
And the woman who was divorced
four times had four dogs,
and the woman who was
divorced five times had five.
And I'm like, well, I have five dogs
and two divorces, so
I'm clearly behind.
I've got room, awesome.
But when I listened to them I
thought you can write that now.
Whoa, got very Italian on you.
Brian, I almost killed myself.
You can write this because the truth
is not everybody has that family.
You're lucky if you have that
nice nuclear thing we all grow
up with, but you know what?
There's a lot of people
who are divorced.
Sadly, there's a lot of
people who are widowed.
And there's all kinds of families
and we're all smarter than that now.
And so I said what I really think
is happening with these women
and these dogs is that women
are making themselves happy,
that maybe there isn't a guy
around loving you or another woman
around loving you, but you can give
love and your heart is full of love.
And it doesn't know the
difference, like if it were
that smart it would be your brain.
That's what I figured
out myself, right?
So I wrote a book called Why
My Third Husband Will Be A Dog,
which is about the real life of
me and my daughter and my mother.
But I think it is really
more importantly about you.
My secret mission is for you
to get the credit you deserve.
And if I said that on the cover
they wouldn't buy the book,
I'd tell them it's an entertaining
story and it kind of is.
So they get the secret message that
women can do really cool things
and they can do funny things
and they can live their
lives however they want to,
and they can drive the roadster
wherever they damn please all
by themselves.
Because I do believe if you're lucky
enough to have somebody with you
in your passenger seat or even
driving you around, you know,
you're still on this road
of life a little bit alone.
In the end you've got to
stand up for yourself.
And so that's what I'm
secretly writing about.
Now to finish I have
sort of made a big point
about this truth, writers
always do that.
I don't think they
explain why that matters,
and that's where you come in.
The reason it matters
if it's true is
because that's the
only way it connects.
I always think to myself when
I'm writing the funny books,
if it doesn't make me cringe
it won't make you laugh.
So I wrote about, for example,
finding my first gray hair
on my chin and realizing I
was turning into an Amish man.
I don't really want to tell you
that, but I have to tell you
that because then you know
what I'm talking about.
Like I was in the hotel room
mirror, I looked, I plucked for you,
is what I'm trying to say and
that shows how much I love you.
And so we do that for you.
And so you want to write
about a woman getting older
on her terms, whatever they are.
I don't have all the
answers, obviously,
I'm trying to figure it out.
But it's true and if
it's true it connects
and that is why the arts matter
and that is why specifically
books matter.
Because when you look at our
society that is so atomized, truly,
we're like we're everywhere.
And we used to have office coolers,
when I was a lawyer
we all went there,
we all talked to our secretaries,
we all had our little
place that we convened.
Not everybody has that anymore.
We're dit, dit, dit, yes?
And we telecommute
and we're skyping.
But at the time, at the same time
that we are farther apart than ever
or alone together, as I saw on the
train today, everybody like this.
The thing that is growing
is book clubs, book clubs,
and you have to understand
that that's the reason.
The reason is because
people want to be together,
they want to share their
thing, they want to open up.
So when I open up emotionally,
I'm going to tell you
something really true,
what it's like to know
you're getting older,
what it's like to lose your mother.
What it's like to lose your kid,
what it's like when your kid
gets beat up in New York City
and you want to kill somebody
but you're not sure who.
Or the good things, when you get a
date, it actually kind of works out,
at least until the third
time, whatever it is.
All the stuff of it, all the
lawyers stand up and forget a case,
figure out what it
is to be a mother,
what it is to be a stepmother.
How are those things different?
All of those things,
if I can just open up
and tell it true it will connect
with you, that's what books do
and that's why books matter.
So that when I - and I know the
proof of it is because when I go
to any book club meeting, because
they'll invite me sometimes,
and I'll go because there's
wine - hi, I'm the author.
And this is what happens, the
first five minutes are always, oh,
in the Rosato Law Firm this and
that, and they ask me questions.
I try to remember the book, I
read the book a year ago - no,
I just make it up, I
never remember anything.
But the next - oh, that's not
really true, but it's hard for me
to remember - the next 15
minutes are all about this.
They start talking about
themselves, their grandkids,
their kids, their new kitchen reno.
And then what will
happen is the same thing,
which is that some woman
will invariably look up,
because women apologize constantly,
and a woman is going
to apologize to me.
And she's going to say,
I'm sorry, we're supposed
to be talking about your book.
And I say the same thing,
which is absolutely true,
and sometimes they even get choked
up when I say it -
I say, but you are.
When you talk about what
part of a book you love
or what part you hate you're talking
about yourself and your own truth.
When you talk about what authors
you love and what authors you hate
or why you love a book,
why does it -
these book clubs have been together
for 10, 20 years and women are
in book clubs, more than one.
Who here is in a book club, anybody?
Of course, right?
How many of 10-year standing?
More than one.
I'm writing Rosato for you because
you are seeing those relationships,
as I see with my best friends.
Those relationships change over time
and you are sharing that intimacy
over time, and I don't think
it happens without a book.
That's why the truth matters
and that's why the arts matter,
and that's why it's so wonderful
that John does everything he does
for the Center of the Book
and all of the 50 states
and why I remember meeting him.
And why he said, will you come here?
And I was like, yes.
Why it's amazing and great
that Laura Bush started it,
why it's amazing and great that the
Obama's continued it and support it,
why the National Book
Festival makes the statement.
Look, we can all talk about
kids' literacy and lots of,
the such good work that many of
you are doing with kids' literacy,
but I don't want to forget about
adults because I feel like we have,
all of us, and particularly women.
You know, we're always doing
so much for everybody else.
We always have the, I always think
of the timeline in
the back of our head.
Gee, what my kid right now, for
example, is finishing her dinner
and then I'm going to
call her at 10 o'clock.
And if you have more than one kid,
and how you did that I don't know,
props to you, you know
all of their schedules,
or you know your mother's
schedule or you know when it's time
for somebody to take their
medicine and you know
that that's every four hours.
You know it.
Women carry so much
of this that I want -
I love that the National
Book Festival says to adults,
take time to read, books matter.
At the national level and a national
statement we are saying not only
for kids, but for adults, too.
Because I know and I read
constantly, thanks to libraries,
that if I spend an hour
reading on the internet,
and believe me I waste time.
Paris Hilton, Gawker, Twitter,
I'm on Facebook, and so I tweeted
about this, hey, come see me.
I love that, but if you
read for an hour online
and then you read an hour a novel
you will feel the difference
in your soul, right?
Because books nurture you, books
heal you, books glue you one
to the other, that's what
matters and that's why you matter
because you are bringing literacy.
I cannot believe it, when John
was showing me this brochure,
which is gorgeous by the
way, that you are doing
that world-wide for people.
I don't know how you
bring about peace and love
and justice any other way.
Books teach empathy,
that's the whole message
of To Kill A Mockingbird.
If you walk in somebody else's
shoes that's how you really
understand them.
And anytime you read a book
you are exercising empathy
because you're in, as Aunt
Beattie [Assumed Spelling] says,
a unified consciousness of
another soul for 400 pages.
And if they're going to write
it true and write it honest,
really open up the heart,
you're going to feel their soul
and I'm going to feel yours.
You, I do that on the micro level
because I get to write them,
but you are doing something
so amazing and so valuable.
And, believe it or not though,
I might not look like the kids
in your countries - I am the kids
in your countries, I was that kid.
I'm a kid from South Philly and
I never would have had a chance
but for what you do for literacy,
for libraries, for all of us.
For the arts, for justice,
for peace and for love.
That's true, I think that's true.
Anyway, thank you.
[ Applause ]
You. Look at me, I got carried away.
Vote for me, it's that time of year.
Now if you have any questions I'd
be happy to answer them, otherwise,
you can go live your lives.
Look, I have no estrogen
left, yet I am schvitzing.
Please?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Lisa Scottoline:
That's so nice to hear.
Thank you, and are you single?
[laughter] I could
have told you that.
Any other questions
or wonderful comments?
Yes, Robert, my favorite person?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Lisa Scottoline: Oh, my God.
Well, I read really widely
because that's all I do,
I mean I have no social life
at this point but I'm kind
of happy, it's imaginary.
I love all the thriller
people because I love -
I think these are stories
about crime and punishment
and I don't think they're -
you know, I just love them.
So I love like Beldotchy [Assumed
Spelling], I love Louise Penny,
I love Jodie Pacole
[Assumed Spelling],
I love Charles Haus [Assumed
Spelling], wonderful,
Harlan Coben [Assumed Spelling].
I also read a lot of nonfiction
because I'm writing memoir,
and so Dana Sadris [Assumed
Spelling] is like I love.
Augustin Burroughs
[Assumed Spelling] I love.
Mary Carr [Assumed Spelling].
I just read a lot.
I think if it's out
there I kind of read it.
Lee Childe [Assumed Spelling].
I mean I just think somebody who
is really stretching and trying
to do what I've said
that I'm trying to do.
I mean how lucky are we, and I feel
like there's so many more books
that there were ever were
before, even self-published books,
I'm so happy that there's so many
avenues for people to have a voice
that there weren't when I
started writing 24 years ago.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Lisa Scottoline: Well,
it's about lawyers, isn't it?
[laughter] I mean long story short,
it is actually because I was very -
I did not know anything about
juvenile justice and I started
to think more and more
about justice issues.
And there was particularly a scandal
that happened in Pennsylvania,
which long story short was called
Kids For Cash, where what happened
and this is exactly how
it happened 13 years ago.
If you were a child and Luzerne
County, Pennsylvania and you got
into a fight in a cafeteria you
were adjudicated - what did you say?
Yes, you were an adjudicated
delinquent, you went right
to prison, without counsel.
There was a waiver form that was
created, you were railroaded.
It turns out that that was
actually because no one knew it
that there was a real life
judicial corruption scheme
where that these two state
court judges were in cahoots
with the builder of the prison
and said if you basically -
they had a part ownership, so
it was a secret deal that went
on which was you send us the
kids, give us a quota of kids,
and we'll send you money back.
Those judges were ultimately
convicted of theft
of honest services and income
tax evasion, are serving 17
and 28 years, respectively.
But I said to myself because I can't
write that, I never do that rip
from the headline stuff, I was much
more interested in in what happens
to the 7,000 kids who that
happened to and what was it
like to be Bennie Rosato?
And the amazing story behind this,
by the way, was a woman founder
of the Juvenile Law Center, Marcia
Levitt, who broke this whole case.
Because what Bennie does comes to
it much, much later, when Bennie -
if you go back in time, Bennie is
representing a kid who basically
in the cafeteria gets
sent to prison.
She can't figure out
how this happened.
She tries to undo it.
It is plainly unconstitutional,
but she keeps losing
and doesn't know why.
And so it's the case
that haunts her.
You might have as a lawyer
the case that haunts you.
I have the case that haunts me.
It just bugs me, still,
25 years ago.
I should have said this,
I should have said that.
I do that all the time.
I'll do it tonight in
the hotel room, oh,
when I said that I
shouldn't have said crowning,
that was really weird.
[laughter] So what happens
with Bennie, in short,
that of course what I wanted
to explore is what happens
to these kids who basically have
their entire lives derailed,
spent three and four years
in juvenile incarceration,
which is no joke incarceration,
at the time when their
adolescent brains were forming.
So I had to research on that,
and how were they ruined
and how can they be made whole.
A Philadelphia law firm about a year
ago tried to get them reparations.
They got them about $5,000 apiece.
Is your child's health and welfare
and very soul worth
more than $5,000?
Of course, but it's
the best they could do.
So I said here's Bennie,
that kid is of, course,
going to grow up to become
an offender of some type.
He's accused of murder.
Bennie finds herself in the
position of defending him.
It's her second chance.
The book is a little
bit on second chances.
And, by the way, she's in love,
she fell in love 13 years ago.
The guy comes back, you know,
he's the one who got away.
And, yes, I wrote a sex
scene for you from memory.
[laughter] I know, I
know, so you get the idea.
It's sort of the case
of her life and the man
of her dreams all at once.
Don't you hate when that happens?
That's Corrupted.
Thank you.
Anything else?
Yes, please?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Lisa Scottoline:
It's really hard.
I mean I get the flip side of that
because I donate a lot
of books to prisons.
Also, then I got some flak from the
Police Academy, why are you giving
to the bad guys and
not the good guys.
I'm like, well, I don't
really think of it that way,
but so now I donate everywhere.
There's Republicans
and there's Democrats,
you've got to like them
both or you're in trouble.
So but I get the same
thing from inmates.
And the only thing I can say and
I think you have - I don't know,
but I think you have a leg
up with kids because I feel
like Harry Potter changed
the world, right?
Because it became a movie, too.
If I talk in schools, and I try
to for the reason that Chris
and I were talking about, I want
them to go, you know, I was you
and you can write a book, honey.
Like that's how - and I'll
tell you how it gets made.
The first person they always
have is it going to be a movie?
Happily my last one is going to be.
I'm like, yay.
But I guess what I'm trying to
say is because it's a movie -
this sounds horrible - but I think
that that gave kids credibility.
I have a lot of moms who will say
to me how do I get my kid to read?
Show them a Harry Potter movie and
then tell them it came from a book.
And what sort of happens
is, and they get lost -
then the kids find the books.
If you've got to do it that way,
because I do think there's -
we all know about bullying and
peer group pressure and you can't -
you know, it's hard to say it's
okay to geek out, but I do that.
And for awhile I was giving
- I had a bunch of books,
I had a bunch of buttons, actually
I was given one by Ron Charles
of the Washington Post,
a Book Editor,
who is the greatest guy ever,
and he gave me his button.
It said, I like big
books and I cannot lie.
And so I bought a bunch of them
and then when I went to his school
and gave that out, and
the kids are like, yeah.
So how do you tell them reading
is not only fundamental but cool?
It's like just keep trying,
that's how I look at it,
but I do think children's literature
has been so much lately, YA,
young adult, too movie that
you almost have a better shot,
almost have a shot.
Because we give a lot of
credibility to movies.
Someday we'll give the
same credibility to books
or at least we do in this room.
Hearing no other questions, thank
you so very much for all you do.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Thank you,
Lisa, that was great.
>> Lisa Scottoline: Thank you.
>> John Cole: I didn't know what
was coming, but it was wonderful.
We now have a book signing of
Corrupted, which is for sale
as of today, published today, and
make sure that she dates that book
and you remember that you were
here on the publication date.
But I also want to say thank you so
much to everyone who came tonight
and thanks especially to
our Best Practices people.
It's really for the Board
members who are still here,
and there are some, it's
really been a wonderful day
and we've topped it off
with some entertainment,
but something quite serious if you
think about it and experience it.
So I think we've come full circle.
Thank you.
We will go to the book signing
if you like, and we will be back
in touch with the Best
Practices people.
Jill is here.
And we've been at you
all day moving you around
and getting you to sign things.
But we promise to be back and to
have a continuing relationship
through the Center for the Book
and our partnership program.
So in many ways it's a beginning,
but it's been a terrific
day and I thank you all.
And I will still be here
to talk with some of you.
We haven't had a chance to
chat, but thanks for everything.
And we hope that we see
some of you soon back
at The Library of Congress.
So I will say goodnight.
And, Jill, let me publicly
thank Jill also for the support.
Let's give Jill a hand.
[ Applause ]
She really - we've
been very flexible.
One of our Board members said
you had to turn on a dime.
We had a quick change in our
arrangements, but it's all worked
out beautifully thanks to everybody.
And, Jill, thanks again.
See you all outside.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.